Okay, so let's begin at July the seventh, 1917.
For one who lives in the divine will, everything is present.
Look at that.
Everything is in action now.
I was fusing myself for my sweet Jesus, but I saw myself as so.
My word says, my book says meager.
We should write down miserable.
I saw myself as so miserable that I didn't know what to give him.
And my beloved Jesus told me, my daughter, for one who lives in my will, there's no past
or future.
All is present in action now.
And just as everything I did and suffered is all present in act now, in such a way that
if I want to give satisfaction to the Father and do good to souls, I can do it as if in
act I were suffering and operating in the same way, what the soul can suffer or do in
my will is already identified with my pains and my work.
Look at that bit and underline it is already identified with my pains and my works and
they become one.
So God lives in the eternal now.
Everything that God does is in act now.
So when we go to Mass, we're actually at Calvary.
We're actually participating in what's going on in Calvary.
And whether we are praying or whatever we're doing, everything is identified with Jesus
and his pains and his works and they become one.
So the value of our prayers and our reparations is infinite because it's divine.
And when the soul wants to give me an attestation of love with her pains, she can take the pains
suffered at other times which are in act and give them to me in order to replicate her
love, her satisfactions for me.
Now I put an N.B. beside that and I'm totally hesitant to make a comment because he seems
to be saying that you can go back to sufferings you've already had and offered to him and
you can re-offer them.
I prefer to take present ones and offer them with his offerings.
But I'll read it for you again.
When the soul wants to give me an attestation of love with her pains, she can take the
pain suffered at other times.
Otherwise, at this moment you may not be suffering any pain.
So you can take all the pain of your life and you can offer it to him.
If they've been done in the divine will, they're in act and you can give them to me to replicate
her love, her satisfactions for me.
And I in seeing the industriousness of the soul who places her acts as though in a bank
in order to multiply them and collect the interest to give me love and satisfaction so
as to enrich her more and not to be outdone with love, I will give her my pains, my works
multiplied and give her love and to be loved.
So everything is identified with him, everything he does is infinite, perfect and eternal.
And he multiplies everything to the infinite.
And just to remind myself of what I'm doing, I just say to him, I want to repeat that for
an infinitude of time.
And I'm just reminding myself he doesn't need any reminder.
Okay.
So July the 18th, 1917, the soul who lives in the divine will lives in Jesus and at his
expense.
It's absolutely incredible and I have a VIP on this.
Continuing in my usual state, I was trying to pour all of myself in the holy will of Jesus.
Now I circled the word trying because sometimes we just struggle with things and you might
think there's something wrong with you if you're struggling at a particular moment.
So realize that Louisa struggled as well.
I prayed him to pour all of himself into me in such a way that I would no longer feel
myself but the whole of Jesus.
Now what Louisa is saying here is probably something that is outside of our experience.
And that is that she was so absorbed in Jesus.
She didn't feel her own body and what was going on in her body.
I'm scratching my body, I certainly feel it and I certainly feel my emotions and all
that kind of stuff.
So what she's saying here is way above anything that would be there for ordinary people like
us.
And the only thing she's aware of is the whole of Jesus.
This is totally absorbed in him.
It's totally amazing.
In fact in a couple of places she complains that she's in such a dryness she can actually
feel her body and I always laugh when I read it.
What's normal for us was abnormal for her.
Of course she's in a bed and she's in a very special, unique vocation and she's in very
unique circumstances so that was God's gift to her.
Jesus said, "My daughter, when the soul lives in my will, everything she does is done in
my volition.
I feel her everywhere."
I've underlined that and read.
I feel her everywhere.
The Lord fills you with him everywhere.
I think that's a fantastic thing.
I feel her in my mind.
I feel her in my thoughts.
I feel her in my mind and her thoughts flow within mine.
See, you can't be at this point if the thoughts are still not worthy of him.
And I defuse the life of intelligence in humanity.
As I defuse the life of intelligence in humanity she defuses herself together with me.
So once we defuse ourselves with him we defuse ourselves throughout the whole of humanity.
So she defuses herself with me in the minds of everyone.
And as she sees me being offended she feels my pain.
Now this is one of the things that the Lord has begun to explain to Louisa that her pains
are not just human pains, they're actually divine, that they're coming from a divine
source.
I feel her in my heartbeat.
Imagine being at that stage.
Even more I feel one heartbeat for two inside of my heart.
Now if you want a definition of union with God you now have it.
And as my love pours into souls she pours herself together with me.
Now notice in the whole process of reproduction he allows us to be co-creators.
In the whole process of redemption he allows us to be co-redeemers.
Look at the humility of God, it's absolutely amazing.
As my love pours into souls she pours herself together with me and she loves with me.
And if I'm not loved she loves me for everyone to recruit me in love and she consoles me.
Now there's one of the great motivations in the divine will mission and that is to do
everything out of this one motivation which is love and to unite that with the love of
Jesus and to make reparation to him for all the on love that's everywhere.
So we try to console him for all the sinfulness of humanity.
In my desires I feel the desire of the soul who lives in my will.
In my works I feel hers in everything.
So our desires and our works and our thoughts and our love all have to be pure.
That means not mixed with selfishness or worldliness or sin or anything like that.
Therefore one can say she lives at my expense, that's Galatians 220.
Galatians 220 I no longer live Christ lives in me.
So Louisa responded my love you do everything by yourself you don't need anyone.
Why then do you love so much that the creature live in your will and live at your expense?
That's of your will.
And so Jesus gives a wonderful answer to this in the next paragraph.
He said indeed I have need of nothing because God doesn't need anything.
I have everything by myself the three divine persons are total and complete they need nothing
outside of themselves.
So but love in order to have life once it's outpouring.
One of the great statements of the saints and the mystics is that love lives by giving.
And this is why in the whole process of marriage the whole thing works if love lives by giving.
But if love wants to live by taking marriage doesn't work as you know.
And so marriage is a one of the ways in which we are given the privilege of expressing God's
love to others.
Love wants it's outpouring.
Imagine a sun which has no need of light it is sufficient for itself and for others.
So this is the example to illustrator.
But still since there are other little lights that's the stars even though it does not need
them it wants them for company to pour itself out and to enlarge the little lights.
This is very important.
First of all we are the little lights Matthew 514.
And I want to give you Mark 3 13 and Mark 6 31.
So Mark 3 13 and Mark 6 31, Lord I believe increase my faith.
Now one of the things that the Lord explains more and more as we go on in Louise's writings
is that in order for us to be able to go on in the divine will he has to enlarge our capacity
we don't have the capacity.
And we start out very very small and he has to gradually gradually gradually enlarge us
until we can take what he wants to actually give us.
So he enlarges the little lights.
What wrong would the little lights not do if they refused?
So the sun is the source of light so if they refuse the sun then they're refusing to have
light and they have darkness.
My daughter when the will is alone it's always sterile.
Now let me give you that in other words self will is sterile.
Her human will is by itself.
It's always sterile love when it is isolated languishes and dies down.
And I love the soul so much that I want her united with my will so as to render her fertile.
My book says fecund which is not a word that we use.
I think the translator had a dictionary that went out of use a couple hundred years ago.
So my will wants to upper be united with her so as to render her fertile and to give her
the life that is love.
That's John 1334.
I want you to love in the same way as I loved.
And I want to give you John 159.
As the father has loved me so I love you.
Now the father has loved the son infinitely, absolutely, eternally, unconditionally knowing
everything about the son.
So the son has loved us infinitely, absolutely, eternally, unconditionally knowing everything
about us.
And then he adds and this is the way you're to love one another.
Now the problem at the base of this that makes a triangle and at the base of this triangle
our problem is that when we know the weaknesses of the other one we don't want to love them.
And so you have to emphasize that the father knew everything about his son and the son
knew everything about us and that is the standard.
So love only has its outpouring when it loves without taking into account that the other
person deserves it or not.
We're inclined to hold back when we say the other person doesn't deserve it.
And of course in saying that the other person doesn't deserve it we've made a judgment.
And of course in making a judgment Jesus says do not judge.
We automatically disobey.
So then Jesus said I found my outpouring because I created the creature only to pour
myself out in love.
Now notice if you look at marriage from this angle it means the two people come together
only to pour themselves out in love and at issues in more life.
So he created us to pour his love into us.
You create others to pour your love into them.
And if love would keep flowing like this we wouldn't be in the dire situation we are
at the moment.
I created the creature only to pour myself out in love nothing else.
And therefore this is my whole commitment.
So July the 25th 1917 Jesus purifies the soul in order to admit
her to live in his will.
Now if you are wanting to reach the fullness of union with God there's one thing
completely guaranteed and that is you will go through the stripping.
Now God is very merciful to us and most of us can't take the complete stripping that
needs to happen all at once we just can't take it all at once.
So what he does is he gives it to you at different stages of your life.
And the stripping is not easy it's very painful.
And when you're going through an operation you're not thinking I'm going to be wonderfully
well when it's all over, all you're thinking of is what you're actually going through.
And so the stripping is very difficult for that reason.
But the result of it is that you shoot forward in the divine will.
What the Lord is doing in the stripping is making room for himself.
Even in my usual state Louisa said I was lamenting to Jesus and I also prayed him to put an end
to the many chastisements that were happening.
And Jesus said my daughter you lament.
This is nothing.
The great chastisements are still to come.
So since this is the middle of World War I the great chastisements are World War II
and World War III.
Now if you think World War III isn't on the cards just go on the internet and they show
you the whole plan for World War III.
And it's not today or yesterday that that plan has been organized.
That's how the powers that be shift political positions among the nations they shift nations
into different blocks.
They change the whole financial set up and the people who have money gain money in the
fall and in the rising.
So he says daughter the great chastisements are still to come.
The creature has rendered herself unbearable.
Now we've been hearing this for a couple of volumes by now.
Under the blows that means World War I she rebels more.
That means that the human race is not ready to surrender to God.
She does not want to recognize my hand that strikes her.
Now unfortunately we're living at a time when everything is explained away.
They will not acknowledge God at all.
I have no other means to use than to exterminate her, her is the human race.
In this way I will be able to remove many lives which infect the earth and kill my growing
generation.
Now he's worried about the new generation, the growing generation.
Okay, I want to give you a Revelation 11, 18.
The second half of that verse says I will destroy the destroyers of the earth.
Those who are bringing about devastation.
Therefore, do not expect an end for now but rather more and worse evils.
There is not, there will not be one place on earth that will not be soaked in blood.
Ireland take note.
He said there will not be one place.
Isn't that amazing?
Okay.
Upon hearing this, Louisa said I felt my heart being lacerated.
And Jesus wanting to cheer me said, my daughter, come into my will and do what I do.
So we fuse with him, we follow what he does and we repeat.
And in my will you will be able to run for the good of all people.
And from within the blood in which they are swimming you will be able to save them with
the power of my volition.
In other words, this terrifying war is actually necessary.
But the amazing thing is that millions of souls were saved under the lash.
That so many soldiers in the trenches actually turned to God, just give one example.
And I remember reading somewhere, I can't remember where it was, that Jesus said to
one of the mystics that from the concentration camps during the Second World War, clouds
of souls rose up to heaven.
That's fantastic, clouds of souls rose up to heaven.
And many of these people are victims for the others, you know.
And within my blood in which they were swimming you will be able to save them with the power
of my volition in such a way as to bring them to me washed in their own blood.
Now that is something that I've come to somehow understand.
And that is that there are some people who will only be baptized in their own blood.
And so there's three ways that you can ask the Lord to baptize souls.
One of them is to have them baptized in water and the spirit, which is normal.
The second one is to have them baptized by desire, yours and his.
He needs yours to do it.
And the third one is that if there's no other way, baptize them in their own blood.
And he said, you can do this with the touch of my will.
In other words, with the divine will, you can do anything.
So I want to give you one Timothy 2 5, God wants everybody to be saved and come to the
knowledge of the truth.
It's not just a small part of the human race you want saved, he wants everyone.
So Louisa said, my life, I am so bad.
How can I do this?
So here's the typical response that all of us give.
So I'm too small or I'm too sinful or I'm too weak or I'm too, I'm too, I'm too, I'm
too.
How can I do it?
So the answer that Jesus gives in the next paragraph, you need to put a VIP on it.
Because he's going to explain the wonder of fusing in the divine will.
So you're going to get the most wonderful reply from Jesus here.
Jesus said, you must know that the most noble, the most sublime, the greatest, the most heroic
act that you can do in my will is to operate in my volition.
There his words, the most noble, the most sublime, the greatest, the most heroic act
is to do my will and to operate in my volition.
So at this act, which no other will be able to equal, I will make a display of the splendor
of all of my love, I've added a few words to make sense in English.
I will make a display of the splendor of all my love and generosity.
In other words, I'll really show you what I can do.
As soon as the soul decides to do it, that's to fuse in the divine will, I, in order to
give her the honor of keeping her in my volition, in the act in which the two wills meet to
be fused into each other and to become one, if she is stained, I purify her.
Please note that because us being ordinary little creatures, it's really not possible
not to have some stains.
Do you know what I mean?
That's a bit like saying, even though your house is as clean as you think it should be
and as tidy, you know, if you really went around and did a deep clean, you'd find something.
Do you know what I mean?
That's just the way it is.
If she is stained, I purify her.
If the thorns of human nature enrap her, I shatter them.
Now that means that we're tending back towards the human will.
And if some nail pierces her, that is sin, I pulverize it because nothing evil can enter
into my will.
That's Hebrews 12, 14.
On holy or unworthy can enter the presence of God.
So while it is absolutely essential for us to keep fusing in the divine will, at the
same time, we're bringing on the Lord's purification on ourselves by doing it because nothing that's
unworthy of him can enter into him.
So we're actually giving him permission to purify us.
But if you look at the teaching that the church gives us on receiving holy communion in grace,
the church teaches us that receiving holy communion in grace actually cleanses you from
venial sin.
It's terribly important.
Unless you're going to persist, okay?
So the church has taught that all the time, that receiving holy communion, if you're receiving
in grace that we say wordily, then the Lord will actually heal us from venial sin.
That means venial sin that you're not actually deliberately doing.
So here the Lord is saying that when we fuse, if she is stained, I purify her.
If the human nature is really wanting to take over, I shatter this.
If the sin is there, now it won't be mortal sin because you can't be in the divine will
with mortal sin.
You can't even be in the divine will with venial sin, but we have indeliberate faults.
He said, I pulverize it because nothing evil can enter my will.
Even more, all my attributes invest her.
I mean, this is incredible.
Now, all his attributes you're talking about, his holiness, his sanctity, his wisdom, absolutely
everything, invest her and change her weakness into fortitude.
Change her ignorance into wisdom and change her misery into richness.
To see why I said we needed to really study this in preparation for drum and team because
all our preparation is here, is absolutely here.
So the Lord changes our weakness into fortitude.
He changes our ignorance into wisdom, and he changes our misery into riches and so with
all the rest.
I think that's divine, don't know about you.
In the other acts, something of herself always remains, but in these acts in the divine will,
she remains completely stripped of herself, and I fill her completely with myself.
So I want to give you SAM 62 there, oh God, you are my God, for you I long, for you my
soul is thirsting.
Even my body pines for you like a dry, weary land without water, SAM 62.
Sorry, SAM 63 it should be, and SAM 62 says I am like it, I'm so weak, I'm like a toughering
wall and a tumbling fence, but SAM 63 gives you this solution to it, okay, and that is
that you long for God and he fills you with himself.
So August the 6th 1917, the divine will renders the soul happy even in the midst of the greatest
storms.
Now, when you're talking about happy, you're not talking about jumping three feet off the
floor, throwing wine or whatever they throw around the place.
What is it, the champagne, you're not talking about that kind of stuff.
That's external bubbly, you know what I mean, that's not it.
He's talking about your innermost being realizes it has found what it was looking for.
And all your innermost being comes together in a piece that passes all understanding.
And that's what he means by happy.
And the more you move into that, the less you feel the need of going out and finding
happiness or joy or anything else, anywhere else.
So I want to give you that as a little thermometer for knowing just where I am in this thing.
Because if we still feel the need that the world has to entertain us and we have to go
out there and something fantastic outside has to entertain us, we need some big concerts,
some big this or that or the other.
That means you have not found this inner total happiness.
This inner total happiness will make you realize that if you stood on a rock in the middle
of the ocean, you'd be totally happy.
And it wouldn't actually matter whether it rained or whether there was a storm or anything
else, it would not affect this happiness.
So I want you to sort of notice this as a thermometer as to where am I in all of this.
So I'll just give you Jesus' message here, Louisa was very afflicted as usual and plenty
of threats of chastisement.
So Jesus said, "Look, my daughter, be cheered.
Do not lose heart too much.
My will renders the soul happy, even in the midst of the greatest storms."
Now, the storms that Jesus is talking about are not the storms that are hitting us from
the Atlantic.
He's talking about storms inside of you, no matter what you're going through.
The amazing thing is that at the deepest level, you're actually happy.
Now, you know I've been giving spiritual direction for many years and one of the things that
if a person comes in, they're struggling with something and they talk to you a lot about
what they're going through.
And at a certain point, you just stop them and you say, "Okay, I got the gist of that
now.
That's my question.
Are you upset in your mind?
Are you upset in your emotions?
Or are you upset in your deepest interior?
Give time.
Think about it."
And it's amazing that's the first time the person has thought about whether it's affecting
me only in my head or only in my emotions.
And I've been absolutely amazed at the number of people who said, "You're the amazing things
I'm okay inside."
I say, "If you're okay inside, we're all okay.
Everything's fine."
But if you let the storm into your innermost being, that's the disturbance that Jesus has
said from Volume 1, will allow the enemy to get a hook into you.
Because sadness or depression or anxiety or whatever will suddenly get a hook.
So when he says you're happy, it means that deep inside of you, this piece that passes
all understanding has entered.
That's Philippians 4.7.
Philippians 4.7, the piece that passes all understanding.
So she can weather even the greatest storms.
Even more, she rises so high that the storms cannot even touch her.
That's what I mean by you ask them, "Is it on the outside or has it gone in?"
She sees them and she hears them.
The place in which she dwells is not subject to storms.
That's your innermost being that has found union with God.
But in there, there's always a serene, smiling sun because her origin is in heaven.
You see, if you're in the divine will, the origin is in heaven.
Her nobility is divine.
Her sanctity is in God, in which she is kept by God Himself.
Because jealous of the sanctity of the soul who lives in my will, Jesus said, "I keep
her in my inmost heart, and I say, 'Nobody touch her.'"
So guess who has to hear that command?
It's the demon.
Nobody's to touch her.
My will is untouchable.
It is sacred and all must give honor to my will.
So in Psalm 62, you will hear at least three times, "In God alone, there is rest for my
soul.
In Him alone, I find safety.
With Him alone for my rock and my fortress, I will never fall."
So it's a case of going into that innermost being.
And so, the answer to everything is union with God.
If in our personal relationship with God, we have reached this union with God, everything
in the divine will just simply be raised to a very high level.
You will understand an enormous amount of stuff that you were struggling with before.
But if you haven't personally reached this stage, then you have to struggle with some
of the things in the divine will and experience things bit by bit.
So August the 14th, 1917, for me, this is an extremely important message.
Jesus alone is our model.
Nobody else.
He is our standard, nobody else.
So Louisa said, "I was in my usual state and Jesus came as usual fleetingly."
And he said, "My daughter, I did nothing other than give myself prey to the will of
the Father."
Now, for this you need the whole of John's gospel, I'll read out some of the references
for you.
This is John's gospel, John 5, 19 to 20, verse 30, verse 36.
You're going to get a whole dose of John now.
I only do what the Father shows me.
I only tell you, say what the Father tells me to say.
I and the Father are one, and it's really fantastic.
So John 7, 16 to 17.
John 8, I only teach what the Father tells me.
John 8, verse 16, 28 and 29.
John 12, 49 and 50.
John 14, verse 10 and verse 31.
Now verse 31 is my absolute favorite because there Jesus says, "I want the world to know
that I love the Father, and therefore I do exactly what my Father tells me."
Now this exact obedience is something that you have seen him demand of Louisa from Volume
1.
This exact obedience.
So that's John 14, verse 10 and verse 31.
So John 15, 9, 15 and 19, and there was two I missed there.
John is John 10, verses 30 and 38, and John 13, 15 and 17.
So you can see that in John's Gospel, Jesus, John is giving us a testimony of Jesus operating
only out of the will of the Father and operating only out of love.
Okay.
Jesus said, "If I taught, I taught in the mind of the Father," Matthew 16, 23.
If I spoke, I spoke in the mouth and with the tongue of the Father.
So he's telling us how we have to operate with him.
If I worked, I worked in the hands of the Father.
Even my breath, I breathed in him.
Now, you see, he's telling us that we have to breathe in him.
Everything that I did was ordered as he wanted.
Now that you need to really color because that's where we're moving into, that everything
in us and everything we do and say and think has got to be in God's order, okay?
Everything I did was ordered as he wanted.
Therefore, I could say that I carried out my life in the Father and watch this.
I was the bearer of the Father.
Just as we have to be Christophirs, that is, bearers of the Christ, okay?
I was the bearer of the Father because I enclosed everything in his will and I did nothing
by myself.
That's John 519.
My main point was the will of the Father because I did not care about myself nor did I interrupt
my course because of the offenses that people gave me, but I kept flying more and more towards
my center, okay?
And only when I fulfilled the will of the Father and everything then did my natural life
and now I want to give you a dose of verses from Luke, okay?
And they may not be in correct order, but I'll try.
Luke 4, verse 1 to 14, which is Jesus in the wilderness, and verse 42, Luke 6, 12, and
the verse is following.
Luke 9, verse 10, 18, 28 to 36.
Luke 11 from verse 1, Luke 21, verses 37 and 38, Luke 22, verses 39 to 46, and Luke 23,
verses 34 and 45.
Now what I'm saying to you there is that the gospels have simply shown us Jesus living
in the divine will and he alone is our model.
Actually Louisa isn't, Jesus is, and we mustn't make the mistake of putting a human being
as our model when she herself has given us Jesus as the model.
So Jesus said, "I kept flying more and more towards my center."
Now that is the journey in the divine will, into union and beyond in the divine will.
And only when I fulfilled the will of the Father and everything then did my natural life
end.
So when are you going to die, when you have completed the will of the Father?
It is the same for you my daughter, if I give you pray to my will, that's Hebrews 12 to,
you will have no more concern about anything.
The very privation of me which torments you and consumes you so much, flowing in my will,
you will find support, you will find my hidden kisses, my life in you all clothed with you.
If you're very heart in your very heartbeat, you will feel mine burning and sorrowful.
And if you do not see me, you will feel me, that's one Peter, one eight.
You do not see him, yet you love him.
My arms hold you tightly.
And how many times do you not feel my motion, my refreshing breath and with that refreshes
your orders?
You do feel this, he said, and when you try to see who squeezed you, who breathes on you
and you do not see me, I smile at you.
I kiss you with the kisses of my will, I think that's divine, isn't it?
And I hide more inside of you, that's Luke 17, 21, in order to surprise you again and
to give you one more jump inside of my will.
In other words, I give you so many opportunities to come back and deepen your relationship with
me.
Therefore, do not sadden me by afflicting yourself, but let me work.
Let the flight in my volition never cease in you.
You see earlier, he said, I kept flying more and more towards my center.
And now he says to Louisa, you keep flying as well.
Keep the flight in my volition, let it never cease in you.
Otherwise, you would hinder my life in you.
While by living in my will, I do not find any hindrance and I make my life grow and carry
out what I want.
So in the next section, Louisa is going to talk about the difference between living in
the divine will and resignation.
Now this is a long message and what I'm going to do here is stop and let you have a break
and we'll pick it up there after the break.
Is that all right?